hello there it's time for more fortnite
myth chasing 69 of them in fact for
season three we have a lot of myths and
dumb signs to get through so let's go is
it possible to use a pickaxe to deflect
a saw blade it comes down to timing but
yeah it's completely possible but it
does look like you have to take 60
damage in the process but how much of a
badass do you look what about darth
vader's lightsaber you know he can block
bullets but what about a saw blade and
holy shizzle he can another myth
confirmed it doesn't even bother him
will this be the same if we take his
saber can we deflect those saw blades
yeah it's true we can with ease so let's
take this to the next level can we
deliberately deflect the saw blades into
the direction of another player check
this out
we can and it's epic so we know the
lightsaber and our own pickaxes can
deflect a blade but what about a harpoon
gun
nope next okay what about a fishing rod
no sadly not how about a shockwave
that'll work won't it no no it doesn't
work and neither does shooting it so
don't even try that moral of the story
avoid the saw blades unless you have a
lightsaber to hand wait there is one
more what happens when two saw blades
collide so let's do this they break into
pieces very satisfying let's get midas
in on this video the king of gold has
always had the ability to change weapons
into solid gold so let's try it with the
new items first the rip saw launcher
yeah it works and even the blade itself
changes colour next it's the turn of the
grapple glove and once again it works
perfectly and now the big one can we
change star wars law and make a golden
hilt for darth vader's blade take a look
at that it's golden midas can indeed
change the lightsaber into pure gold
probably the most epic thing you'll see
today i love gold
hey midas's cat friend is now on the
island i wonder what happens if midas
speaks to meowsles
oh he says whoa are we getting back
online to me this means midas crew is
coming back soon but i'm likely wrong
so the grapple glove is here is it
possible to grapple onto a shark i don't
know why you'd want to do this but yep
myth confirmed can we grapple a bird in
the air this is confirmed but the bird
despawns pretty quickly so it's a
useless ability if i'm honest and
sometimes it will actually glitch and
the grapple will latch onto the airspace
the bird was previously in which is
weird but also cool speaking of weird
here's another one i'm told if you
remove the grapple glove from your
inventory whilst you're using it on the
very last charge you will stay in the
hanging animation the item in your hand
can be changed but you are stuck here
completely even when everything is
destroyed around you just sort of
hanging there this one must be a bust
it's possible to build whilst using the
grapple glove okay let's try it oh damn
it is fortnite 90s will never be the
same again
back to mr vader is it possible to get
anakin in the slipstreams around the
rave cave let's do it so i totally
messed up my shockwave throw but luckily
the harpoon strap works well too and
there he goes zooming through the air
completely loving life in fact this
leads to another myth what glider does
darth vader have check it out it's the
imperial shuttle i've been trying this
myth on every character since chapter
one and this is the first time it hasn't
been the default glider but what about
the stormtroopers we grabbed a riff to
go and tested it out
and yep they have defaults rip i've also
tried this on many npcs this season but
let's try another one from the latest
update thick boy kyle and i can confirm
the same default glider is here
hopefully in future more npcs will get
personalized gliders but for now darth
vader is the one and only
vader has the power of telekinesis he
can move things with the force he yeets
us around with ease but will he do it if
we're sat in a vehicle check it out hell
yeah he loves it
here's a pretty complex myth can vader
levitate a vehicle he's currently stood
on okay i tried this for an hour and
failed miserably but luckily someone has
already done it royal mishmash recorded
vader eating a car he was stood on top
of very epic can darth vader swim this
one was easier than i thought as one
game he just jumped straight in the
water and look he frolicked around he's
quite happy there myth confirmed vader
can swim much better than the cube queen
this one is quite interesting vader
becomes enraged if he touches sand so
much law here to unpack so we jumped in
and shocked waved the big man over there
and well nah he isn't bothered one iota
about the sand i don't like sand okay a
big one now can we save vader sabre in
our own tents there's not a chance right
well yeah it's possible totally is which
means it's also possible to have a team
of four all with vader's saber check
this how awesome does that look so
vader's lightsaber has the ability to be
thrown can we block it with another
lightsaber yes we can and it looks
completely epic we had a four-player
saber scrap in the final circle it was a
battle of the ages in fact i think we
need 100 players with 100 lightsabers in
their tents for a massive brawl anybody
up for it discard fam
more myths and a dumb world record now
can you juggle a shark with a saw blade
this took time to get right but it's
definitely possible five is my current
record and i challenge you to beat me
how many kpis can you do with a shark on
a single saw blade is it possible to
gain saw blade ammo by using the repair
tool i'll try it i guess nope you'll
just start a fire and just in case
you're wondering you cannot gain ammo
from using the petrol pumps either you
just look a bit insane let's check how
many of each material type a single saw
blade can cut through for wood it's
exactly eight walls for brick it's five
and a half walls and for metal it's four
exactly and if you're wondering an
armored wall will take the whole brunt
of a saw blade but there'll be enough
juice left over to roll into the next
tile useful info for somebody out there
i think most people know this one but
just in case after taking the fruit from
your sapling it's possible to regrow it
instantly by using a shield keg or chug
splashes but would this work on a mythic
fruit when the time came and my fruit
was ready i went over there and after
collecting my mythic i threw down a
shield keg by that time though the tree
had already withered away so i found a
friend with a mythic and this time i
threw down the keg before he took the
mythic berry sadly same result though
only a single mythic is possible
back to anakin we go one last time does
darth vader spot players hiding in
bushes well see for yourself he doesn't
myth confirmed but the moment you make
contact with him or shoot from distance
he'll know exactly where you are and
come running he takes no prisoners a
burning question i had about darth vader
is if he can identify us when we are
disguised as props i was a barrel and my
friend was a box so we ran over there
excited and um yeah instantly they know
who you are and they didn't fall for it
at all the empire is on to your tricks
totally random myth now can sharks use
launch pads well they could in chapter 2
and yes they can still use them in
chapter 3. what happens when a saw blade
goes into the slipstreams it turns out
that the saw blade is light enough to
stay in the airstream until it is
destroyed and we also checked if we
could get an elimination you can myth
confirmed myth mystique shapeshifting
emote no longer works against npcs in
fortnite no way this can't be true let's
test it out oh no it is true
i'm kidding in fact don't worry at all
it only works in real games now it no
longer works in battle labs for some
reason so jump into any public match and
you can become any of the npcs including
unreleased skins like thick boy kyle and
the trespasser chilling with bill and
ted by the way here's team thick sharing
a moment it's not a myth i just think
it's something we all need to see and
finally two big myths to end who wins a
fight between the foundation and vader
this one was surprisingly easy to set up
as darth could land very close to dwayne
from there we used a few shock waves and
fishing rods and the battle began
long story short the foundation's damage
output was too high for vader's low
damage abilities and although anakin was
on the front foot that huge testicle
ability the foundation throws was the
game changer officially the foundation
absolutely wiped the floor with vader i
wonder if that will ever be in star wars
canon
okay to end now did you know that a saw
blade can do this to a vehicle weird
isn't it by smashing the windscreen and
throwing a blade inside the impact
causes the vehicle to slowly raise off
the ground so it got us thinking what
happens if we do this in battle labs
when the vehicle doesn't take any damage
at all how high could we get our record
is
182 meters high only using saw blades i
now challenge you to beat that pointless
world record so that's our list of myths
did we miss anything please let me know
in the comments if you have any dumb
science you'd like us to test here's a
bunch of legends from my discord who
used my code this week thank you very
much if you did and i'll see you again
next time
[Music]